Hallo Guten Tag, ich bin hier aus Asistan, Arsdien-Tatik. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Helga Schmidt. Ja, Frau Helga Schmidt.
Mit DT? Mit DT richtig.
Frau Schmidt, vor dem Gespräch würde ich Personal erfangen. Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden.
Was für Beschwaden haben Sie?
Frau Doktor, es geht um meine Finger, die jetzt vor allem im Winter kalt werden, dann blass werden, wo ich dann auch ein bisschen Schmerzen habe.
Das ist nicht immer, aber das stört mich zunehmend. In den letzten Wochen hat das jetzt zugenommen, die Häufigkeit, dass die Finger blass werden und ich dann Schmerzen bekomme.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Eigentlich schon seit zwei, drei Monaten, aber in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen ist es häufiger geworden. Das ist fast täglich.
Wie haben Sie die Veränderung in Iran bemerkt?
Ja, Frau Doktor, das ist immer ähnlich. Die Finger werden auf einmal ganz blass, auf beiden Händen, aber das ist nicht immer die gleichen Finger, muss ich dazu sagen.
Dann tun die ein bisschen weh und wenn ich es ein bisschen bewege, werden die sogar ein bisschen blau.
Nach fünf bis zehn Minuten werden die dann rot, die Finger. Dann lässt es langsam nach. Das stört mich sehr.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Händengelenk?
Eigentlich nicht, aber ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe eine Krankheit, die bei den Gelenken auch mir Beschwerden gemacht hat.
Das ist vor drei, zweieinhalb Jahren festgestellt worden, von Rheumatologen, als Dermatomyositis.
Da hatte ich auch Gelenkeschwerden, auch in den Händen, in den Fingern auch ein bisschen.
Schwächer gab es in den oberen Schengeln, die Haut im Gesicht war rot gewesen.
Das war damals, habe ich viele Ärzte besucht und letztendlich hat dann der Rheumatologin gesagt, dass das Dermatomyositis ist.
Ist Dermatomyositis gut behandelt?
Am Anfang habe ich Kortison bekommen und zuletzt habe ich das mit MTX eingestellt. 15 Milligramm pro Woche.
15 Milligramm pro Woche?
Genau, damit bin ich jetzt seit längerer Zeit ohne größere Beschwerden, bis auf diese Finger jetzt.
Ja, jetzt Finger.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Also ich war jetzt auch vor zwei, drei Wochen erkältet längere Zeit, aber es war kein Corona, da habe ich auch Testen machen lassen.
Und da habe ich halt viel Medikamente genommen, wie Paracetamol, die Nase verstopft, auf Nasentropfen genommen.
Also ein bis zwei Wochen pass, habe ich mit der Erkältung zu tun gehabt.
Haben Sie Luftnot?
Habe ich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Konzentrationprobleme?
Kann ich so nicht sagen, nein.
Haben Sie Husten?
Momentan nicht, also als erkältet war, war ein bisschen Husten, aber jetzt habe ich keine Husten.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gewicht verloren?
Ich hatte damals, als ich Kortison genommen hatte, zugelassen, aber jetzt in den letzten halben Jahren,
in einem Jahr habe ich mein Gericht gehalten, ich habe ungefähr 67 Kilogramm, das habe ich jetzt gehalten.
Haben Sie Probleme auf der Wasalasen oder beim Stuhlgang?
Jetzt aktuell nicht, nein.
Haben Sie irgendein Werte andere Schmerzen?
Eigentlich nicht jetzt, also wegen der Mathormeositis sind die Beschwerden einigermaßen unter Kontrolle, habe ich jetzt.
Ja, Sie haben Ihre Finger werden kalt und rot gewertet.
Erstmal sind Sie ganz blass, dann weiß.
Und dann rot gewertet.
Und wie lange dauert dieser Matzak?
Also 10 Minuten, maximal 10 Minuten.
Wie alt sind Sie?
40 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie? Sie haben erwähnt, Sie sind 72 Kilogramm.
67?
Und ich bin 1,70 Meter groß.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Außer der Dermatomyositis eigentlich nicht, nein.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als junge Frau war ich 17 Jahre alt, appendicitis.
Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein.
Haben Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Nein, sonst keine.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, ich bin keine Bekannte.
Brauchen Sie Fleisch mit?
Ja, ich rauche leider ja.
Wie viele Zigaretten pro Tag?
Also 10 Zigaretten pro Tag, eine halbe Schachtel Zigaretten.
Seit wann?
Auch schon seit, jetzt bin ich 40, habe mit 16 angefangen.
Über 20 Jahre bestimmt schon.
Ja, 24 Jahre.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, nicht regelmäßig, nur wenn ich irgendwo zum Essen eingeladen bin.
Oder wenn ich einen Anlass ergibt.
Die nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, ich habe keine Erfahrung mit Drogen.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Alzahn gesund?
Meine Mutter hat auch eine gründliche Erkrankung.
Die hat Morbus Pech-Terev.
Und mein Vater, der ist auch Braucher und hat auch diese COPD-Krankheit.
COPD.
Wie alt ist Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist jetzt ungefähr 65.
Und wie alt ist Ihr Vater?
Er ist 2 Jahre alt, 67.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin eigentlich Lehrerin.
Aber ich bin jetzt seit der Krankheit auch krankgeschrieben, seit fast 2 Jahren.
Seit 2 Jahren?
Ja, habe zwar jetzt versucht eine Wiedereingliederung,
aber das habe ich dann wieder pausiert.
Es ist noch nicht ganz klar, wie es weitergeht, ob ich Rente einreichen muss,
Erwerbs- und Fähigplatzrente oder ob ich noch mal arbeiten kann.
Das muss noch geklärt werden, ist noch nicht entschieden.
Ja, okay.
Sie würden, ich glaube, für ich in der Rente gehen.
Das haben die mir nahegelegt, aber ich möchte nicht.
Ich möchte gerne noch weiterarbeiten.
Ja, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin ledig.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Reise gemacht?
Nein, das ist schon über 2 Jahre her, letzte Reise.
Und sind Sie gegen Corona vollständig geimpft?
Ja, 2 Jahre. Nein, noch nicht.
Noch nicht, okay.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Probleme?
Das wären die Wichtigsten, die ich Ihnen erzählt habe, Frau Doktor.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe alle Informationen bekommen.
Gibt es noch andere Fragen oder gibt es etwas,
was Sie mir sagen möchten?
Ich kann mal kurz in den Chat reingucken.
Vielleicht gibt es Fragen, die die Zuhörer stellen wollten.
Gibt es noch Fragen, die Sie gestellt hätten?
Haben Sie Krippeln im Finger?
Und welche Finger? Die beide Finger oder die alle Finger?
Nein, das sind auf der rechten Seite Zeigefinger und Mittelfinger.
Und auf der linken Seite ist Mittelfinger und Ringfinger.
Die sind betroffen.
Fühlen Sie sich Krippeln?
Wenn es länger ist, dann habe ich auch Krippeln.
Okay.
Das ist eine richtige Frage, welche Finger betroffen sind.
Ja.
Haben Sie etwas, was machen Sie für die Verbesserung?
Ich möchte nur bewegen, oder?
Fieber habe ich nicht.
Über Wärmung der Finger kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Die Finger werden aber auch rot, habe ich gesagt.
Erst blau und danach werden sie rot.
Dann sind sie vielleicht schon erwärmt.
Aber das kann man jetzt nicht so gut feststellen.
Weil der Temperatur und den Finger dann auch gestört ist.
Da kann ich nicht so gut fühlen, ob es überwärmt ist.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere Fragen.
Haben Sie Stress?
Ja, beruflich habe ich Stress.
Wenn Sie Stress haben, nehmen wir Schwerden zu.
Den Stress kann man nicht so gut fassen.
Der ist immer da.
Deswegen kann ich nicht sagen, dass das das Zunimmt mit Stress.
Haben Sie Apotheber zugenommen?
Nein, hat sie gefragt.
Gewichts des Gleich.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Keinen Unfall.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Am besten mit der Skala.
Kopf- oder Mackenschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Die Schmerzen sind so, aber der Skala von 1 bis 10,
zwei bis drei.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Nein.
Weitere gute Fragen?
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen lindert?
Ja, wenn ich die Finger reibe und so warm mache,
dann wird es besser.
Oder Handschuhe an Sie, wenn ich draußen bin?
Die ganze Jahreszeit haben Sie Fingerschmerzen?
Oder nur im Winter?
Es ist ja neu angefangen, deswegen kann ich es noch nicht sagen.
Aber seit zwei, drei Monaten hat sie es?
Oder habe ich es?
Und seit zwei, drei Wochen bis jetzt Winter wird es mehr,
also häufiger.
Familienanamnese haben wir gefragt, da gab es diese Beschwerden nicht.
Neurotermittes ist mir nicht bekannt in der Familie.
Aber sind Sie Urin-Probleme?
Nein, das ist gefragt worden.
Urin und Stuhlgang ist normal gewesen.
Gut, aber jetzt haben wir noch ziemlich viele Fragen nochmal gestellt.
Medikamente haben Sie gefragt, glaube ich, gell?
Ja.
Haben Sie gefragt?
Ja, also nur MTX, sonst keine anderen.
Doch, Sie hat was gesagt, Sie hat Nasentropfen genommen.
Und Paratidamol wegen der Geltung.
Sonst noch Fragen?
Jetzt sehe ich keine.
Machen Sie weiter?
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstdiagnose bei der Patientin?
Ja, vielheit.
Ich habe verdacht auch Renofenomen.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, nur das Weichen gelb.
Renosyndrom, ja, richtig.
Ja, richtig.
Aber nur das Weichen gelb, Renome.
Kann sein, kann nichts sein.
Wer will das was zu sagen?
Renofenomen, Renosyndrom, kann man auch sagen, ja.
Ja, also es gibt ja verschiedene Formen vom Renow.
Es gibt es primäre Renosyndrom, also ohne bekannte Ethiologie.
Da sind die Finger meistens symmetisch betroffen.
Es können alle Finger sein, also mit Ausnahmedaumen ist meistens nicht betroffen.
Es können alle Finger sein, aber es können immer auch ein paar Finger sein.
Und dann gibt es noch die sekundäre Renow.
Können wir gleich noch besprechen, was da der Unterschied ist.
Machen Sie vielleicht erst mal weiter mit Ihrer Vorstellung?
Oder wollen Sie schon zur Oberarztvorschlelung übergehen?
Ja, vielleicht.
Okay.
Hallo, Herr Aburax.
Ich bin Dienstabendarztin.
Und ich habe einen neuen Patientin gerade gesehen.
Und ich würde ihr Fall mit Ihnen teilen.
Es handelt sich um Frau Helde Schmid.
Sie ist 40 Jahre alt, 67 kg schwer und 170 groß.
Die Patientin klagt über die Fingerschmerzen.
Die Patientin erwähnt, dass die Schmerzen in der Zweihter und dritte Begette in der linken Hand
und in der dritten und vierte Begette in der rechten Hand treffen.
Und diese Schmerzen seit zwei, drei Monaten aufgetreten.
Aber seit zwei, drei Wochen schlimmer geworden.
Außer, dass die Patientin die Finger zuerst blieb, dann blieb und dann rötig.
Langsam rötig.
Und dann war ich mit der Begette in der rechten Hand.
Ich habe mit der Begette in der rechten Hand gekauft.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben ja beschrieben, dass die Patienten die Finger erst blass, dann blau und dann rötig.
Können Sie erklären, warum das so wird?
Warum werden die Finger blass?
Das gefällt mir nicht ein.
Welche Blutgefäße bringen das Blut in den Finger?
Die heißen Arterien oder Arteiol.
Hauptsache eine Arterie, die den Finger versorgt, hat meistens ein Spasmus, mit Eng.
Dann kommt es zur Durchblutungsstörung, das ist kein Blut, deswegen ist es erst mal blass.
Warum werden die dann blau, manchmal, bei den Finger?
Das sind Akrozianose, die Wäden erweitern sich dann, deswegen werden sie blau,
wenn der Sauerstoff nicht kommt, dann ist das Blut nicht oxygeniert,
die Wäden sind meistens bläulich durchschimmern, dann sind sie blau.
Und später werden die Finger dann rote, was ist das für einen ...
Wieder kommt der Sauerstoff.
Das ist eine reaktive Hyper-Emi, meistens stärker durchsprült.
Wissen Sie das nennt manche Mal, diese drei Farben bei Renault?
Wissen Sie nicht, wissen?
Nein.
Da steht aber hier drin, hat jemand geschrieben, Tricolore Phänomen, richtig.
Tricolore Phänomen, weil es an dieser Farben wie bei der Französischen Flagge ausmacht.
Was ist das für eine Krankheit?
Ist das behandelbar oder was würden Sie der Patient empfehlen?
Ja, ähm ...
Oder andersrum gefragt, schuldigung, bevor Sie antworten.
Ich habe ja schon eingangs gesagt, dass es zwei Formen gibt.
Das ist die primäre Renault-Syndrom, das sekundäre Renault-Syndrom.
Beim Primär hat man keine Ursache, weiß man natürlich nicht.
Das ist so idiopathisch vielleicht.
Bei der sekundären wissen Sie, warum das Sekundär heißt?
Sekundäre Renault?
Ja, sekundäre Rheimo, ähm ...
Manchmal treten mit anderen romatologischen Krankheiten zusammen auf.
Okay, okay.
Aber ...
... kann ich leider nicht mehr.
Macht nichts.
Gibt es auch andere Krankheiten außer rheumatologischen Krankheiten, die eine Renault machen können?
Hm ...
... sehle, sehle, sehle ...
Also es gibt ja auch hermatologische Erkrankungen, die so was machen können.
Welche ist das machen können?
Lupus ... Lupus ... Lupus ... Lupus Rheumatologisch hat sich schon gesagt, aber hermatologisch hat jemand schon gesagt,
sehe ich grad ... PNH, was ist PNH, für eine Abkürzung?
Von alle?
Polymyositis?
Nee, PNH ist Abkürzung, wofür?
Herr Hennach.
Noch mal?
Und noch ein paar Gsmale nächtliche Hämoglobinorie auf Deutsch, ja, genau.
PNH, das ... das stimmt, sehr wohl.
Lupus haben wir gesagt, Kryoglobulinämie, ja.
Kryoglobuline können das mal machen.
Sklerodermie gehört zu den rheumatologischen Erkrankungen im weitesten Sinne, ja.
Und also es gibt zum Beispiel auch bei einer ... bei einer ...
... Polyzitämie-Aware, oder auch eine Polyzitämie, also eine Vermehrung von ...
... Erotropzytten, roten Blutkörperchen.
Und dann kann man eine Renovänomenssyndrom verursachen.
Oder auch mal Paraportinivisen, zum Beispiel bei multiple Myolom, ...
... vorkommen können.
Können auch manchmal Ursache sein für eine Renov.
Ja.
Burgers.
Bitte?
Ich hab's nicht ganz ...
... Vinivatar-Bürger, meinen Sie das, als was gut ist?
Ja, Rauchen, mein Burgern.
Rauchen, ja, ist auch ein Faktor, das es verschlechtern kann,
das ist nicht Premiere, das ist Auslösung, glaube ich, ja.
Gut, jetzt haben wir die rheumatologischen Ursachen,
die hermatologischen, da gibt's noch Rauchen, ja,
und was noch, gibt's noch zwei Sachen.
Vielleicht Medikamente, ich weiß es nicht, aber ...
Richtig, richtig, genau, Medikamente können nur nur aussehen, ja.
Was ist so der Klassiker für Renov, Medikamente?
Veterbüderkirch.
Veterblocker, Veterblocker, zum Beispiel, ja, genau.
Veterblocker oder auch Chemotherapeutika, so was finden,
das Auslösen oder diese abschelten Nasentropfen,
deswegen hab ich's gesagt, ja.
Also, alles, was so ein bisschen gefängstaktive Substanz enthalten wird,
Ergotamin oder andere ...
... war so sphastische Medikamente.
Gut, und noch eine Sache, was ...
... macht das Rauchen bei vielen Patienten?
Also, es macht zwar jetzt nicht direkt ein Renov,
aber was kann es Rauchen machen, was zu einem Renov führen kann?
Ja, sich verschlechtert kann, verschlechtert kann,
deswegen ... ja, Lebensgewohnheit, Veränderung ist ...
Muss man dann auch aufhören.
Aber was machen, dass das Rauchen mit den Gefäßen ...
... aktiv ist, die Geröse.
Mhm, genau.
Und wenn man das ...
Richtig, genau. Also, das ist auch PAVK.
Wenn es mal in Händen oder an den Armen wäre,
dann kann es auch mal ein Renov verursachen.
Ein sekundäres Renovsyndrom, ja.
Das meine ich damit richtig, genau.
Hat jemand noch gefragt gehabt vorhin im Chat ...
... mit Hinweis auf eine ...
... Kolargenose, glaube ich, haben Sie schlucken,
Schmerzen beim Schlucken, glaube ich, gell?
Hat jemand gefragt, das habe ich vorhin mal gesehen gehabt.
Trockenermonstluckbeschwerden, ja, warum fragt man das?
Welche Tagart ist das, die Schluckbeschwerden macht?
Ja, vielleicht mit der Trucksatzkampen macht.
Nee, wer hat das gefragt?
Ich sehe grad, Herr Elvan hat gefragt, warum hat er das gefragt?
Nichts, ja, Schürgrenz.
Oh, Elvan, Elvan.
Was für eine Krankheit kann das machen?
Trockenermonstluckbeschwerden.
Schürgrenz, ja, bestätigt.
Mit jemandem Antworten darf ich wohl.
Ist schon gestellt worden, ja.
Sklerodermie, ja.
Sklerodermie, also gehört auch zu den Kolargenosen, ja.
Alles während die häufigsten Ursachen für ein sekundäres Renau.
Wie diagnostizieren Sie ein primäres Renau-Syndrom?
Oder bestellen Sie die Diagnose?
Die Diagnose ist klinisch, diagnostiziert.
Und wie können Sie sagen, ob es primär oder sekundär ist?
Ich glaube, primäre.
Ja, primäre, wegen Rauch.
Kann ja auch ein Aufhauker sein, oder?
Dann wäre es sekundär, ne?
Ja, ja, sekundär.
Was ist primär?
Wie kann man sagen, dass es primär ist?
Erstens kann man sagen, wenn man keine Ursache gefunden hat,
eine andere Kagan ist primär, das wäre ein Aufschlussdiagnose.
Aber manchmal kommen auch die Krankheiten erst später zum Vorschein.
Deswegen ein Renau-Syndrom, was jetzt, sag ich mal, keine Grunderkrankung hat.
Länge als zwei Jahre besteht, wird man als primäres Renau-Phenomen bezeichnen, ja.
Was gibt es noch für Charakteristika bei einem Primären
im Gegensatz zu einem sekundären Renau?
Ich habe es immer, aber wird oft ein Literatur erwähnt, was sein kann.
Wissen Sie das?
Denken Sie mal daran, wie die Finger der Patienten befallen waren,
welche Finger befallen waren.
Ja, vielleicht, die Primäre Renau treffen alle Finger.
Kann sein, ja.
Also meistens der Daumen nicht betroffen, ja, aber die restlichen Finger, ja.
Was kann noch sein?
Primäre Renau vielleicht hat keine Schmerzen.
Schmerzen kann bei beiden sein, muss aber nicht, haben Sie recht, ja.
Aber denken Sie mal, was Sie gesagt haben, rechts so und links so.
Ja, Primäre Renau treffen gleiche Finger, vielleicht.
Ja, wie nennt man das dann?
Ist ja nicht die gleichen Finger, aber ...
Symmetrik.
Symmetrik, aber Fall.
Ja, also häufig so, dass es Symmetrik ist.
Wenn es asymetrik ist, ist es oft ein sekundäres Problem,
was einfach auch organische Störungen in den Blutgefäßen auch meistens hat.
Ja, also durch Kollagenosen oder auch durch Vasculartiden oder was auch immer.
Und Sie haben auch schon erwähnt, beim Primären ist meistens auch der Bezug
dazu, Kälte oder Stress, dass es immer ausgelöst wird.
Das ist ein Argument für eine Primäre Renau-Syndrom.
So, was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Sie haben schon gesagt, sie soll aufhören zu rauchen.
Was soll sie noch machen oder kann man noch helfen?
Sie muss die Trigäre versichten.
Noch mal?
Trigäre Faktoren versichten.
Triggerfaktoren, ja.
Kälte oder bestimmte Situationen.
Wenn Sie jetzt rausgehen, was sagen Sie dann?
Wenn Sie jetzt im Winter rausgehen, was soll sie machen?
Sie müssen Handschuhe trauen.
Genau, genau.
Kann man auch Medikamentös gegen Renau was machen?
Wenn die Gärme Handschuhe und Trauchen aufhören,
nicht geholfen hat, dann sind wir wiederkommen.
Kälte oder Antagonisten?
Man kann versuchen mit Kälte und Antagonisten zu behandeln.
Manchmal hilft es, oft auch nicht, muss ich dazu sagen.
Es gibt auch viele andere Medikamentiere,
die man auch gewinnen können,
aber primär werden Kälte und Antagonisten wie Nivellipin.
Möglich als Medikamentösotherapie.
Okay, das wäre so das Wichtigste, glaube ich.
Hat sonst jemand noch einen Kommentar oder eine Frage?
Zudem Thema Renau-Syndrom.
Ich gucke gerade mal im Chat,
ob wir alle Kommentare gelesen haben.
SLD, also Lupus-Konzain,
Lupus eritomatodes als Goliagenose.
Lupus chiroglomimis, Glerodermis, Zyrgon-Syndrom, ja.
Alles mögliche Ursachen.
Grunder kamen sie an Renau-Phänomen zu Ursachen.
Gut, bitte schön.
Verscha antikörpia, das haben wir anmerkt.
Für die Diagnose?
Ja, antikörpia z.B. ANA, ANK, oder...
Kommt drauf an, was für Verdachtstiagnose sie haben.
Wenn sie z.B. Verdacht auf Lupus haben,
machen sie meistens ANA oder Anti-Doppelstang-DNS-Antikörper.
Das würde helfen.
Bei Glerodermis z.B. kann dieses Anti-SCL 70 machen.
Und je nachdem, welche Verdachtstiagnose sie haben.
In Rheumatologie kenne ich mich jetzt nicht ganz gut aus,
aber es gibt da so verschiedene Antikörpoklassifikationen.
Die helfen, können die Diagnose stellen.
Manchmal kann man die auch nicht stellen mit Antikörpoklassifikationen.
Wenn die Anzendeparameter normal sind,
können die auch auf Antikörpia am Ende.
Wenn sie nicht die Ursache können, würde ich machen.
Wenn sie das nicht eindeutig klären, würde ich machen.
Abheims ist die Anzendeparameter.
Genau.
Oder auch so die Eiweiß-Elektrophoris und solche Sachen.
Oder nach Kälterklinien oder Kyoglopolyne würde ich machen.
Bei den Jungpatienten mit der ersten Enzyme-Renow würde ich das machen.
Okay, dann haben wir noch Kommentare oder Fragen zum ersten Fall.
Ich würde nicht sagen, es war eine gute Vorstellung.
Prüfung bestanden, oder?
Nein.
Warum nicht?
Es geht nicht um Fachwissen.
Das ist sehr speziell, was ich gefragt habe.
Es geht aber wie Sie die Frage stellen.
Nein, die Anamnese erheben war ich besser früher,
aber jetzt gibt es noch zehn Tage.
Ich habe so viel nervös und ich habe nicht gut Anamnese erheben.
Am besten Checklist zu machen, was man bei Anamnese alles fragen sollte.
Manchmal muss man bei bestimmten Symptomen die Tiefe gehen.
Manchmal kann man die überspringen.
Das hilft dann, Checklist zu machen.
Aber sonst war es gut.
Spachlich war es sehr gut.
Danke.
Alles klar.
Okay, ich habe keine Geczegnis.
Herzlich Willkommen!
Ich comprendete, Herr Ahmed!
Was ist Ihreplin?
Ich habe die Job des Kinderanstaltungen, aber ich habe nicht getroffen.
Habe einen Algemein!
Hallo, ich bin Mehmet Sehlen.
Ich habe das Aus bombing bes wiele Strukturen.
würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sie sind damit einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden, Herr Doktor.
Okay, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, geben Sie mir Bescheid,
bitte, dass ich Ihre Daten sprechen möchte.
Wie heißen Sie das?
Mein Name ist Harald Begemann.
Könnte Sie langsam Bustavieren?
Harald mit H, A, R, A, L, D.
Harald und der Nachname ist Begemann.
B, E, G, E, M, A, N.
Begemann.
Herr Begemann.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
41, wann sind Sie genau geworden?
21. März 81.
81.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,80 m.
1,80 m groß und ich spiege 78 kg.
78 kg.
Richtig.
Herr Begemann, wie kann Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe Fieber.
Seit mehreren Tagen.
Ich fühle mich seit einer Woche nicht gut.
Ich habe Fieber mit Spitzten an.
Ich hatte Fieber.
Letzten Sonntag.
Dann war es zwei Tage gut.
Dann hatte ich am Mittwoch wieder Fieber.
Letzte Woche.
Dann war es zwei Tage gut.
Dann habe ich fast jeden Tag Fieber.
Es gibt bis 38, 39 Grad.
Manchmal hatte ich auch Schüttelfrost.
Jetzt habe ich nur noch diese Fieberschübe.
Herr Begemann, Sie haben Fieber.
Das Fieber ist nicht jeden Tag.
So ein Tag Pause.
Und noch mal geht es hoch.
Sie haben gemessen 39 Grad.
Manchmal hat man noch 30 Grad.
Aber jetzt habe ich seit zwei Tagen Fieber.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Schüttelfrost.
Manchmal hatte ich auch Schüttelfrost.
Letzten Tag habe ich jetzt kein Schüttelfrost.
Haben Sie auch Nachtschweiß?
Ich schwitze auch nachts.
Sie haben etwas Schmerzen.
Oder eine Schmerz.
Ich fühle mich insgesamt sehr ...
Ich habe ein Krankheitsgefühl.
Ich habe auch Übelkeit.
Ich habe zwar nicht erbrochen.
Der Stuhlgang ist auch nicht mehr so.
Ich hatte auch mal Durchfall.
Es war nicht richtig Durchfall.
Aber so dünner Stuhl, Breihe gewesen.
Einmal, zweimal.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen.
Aber ich fühle mich insgesamt ziemlich krank.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der Weste seit Gewicht verblüßt?
Also jetzt habe ich den letzten Tagen nicht gemessen.
Aber vorher, bevor ich das Fieber hatte, war alles normal.
Vielleicht habe ich jetzt durch dieses Fieber und Übelkeit.
Und Durchfall vielleicht ein bisschen verloren.
Aber ich habe mich nicht gewogen.
Nicht so viel.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser lassen?
Nicht so richtig.
Vielleicht war die Farbe mal ein bisschen dunkler.
Aber ich habe auch wenig getrunken.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das will ich jetzt nicht zu überbewerten.
Wie ist Ihr Rapetit?
Der ist schlecht.
Ich habe auch Übelkeit.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen Druckgefühl im gesamten Bauchbereich.
Vor drei Tagen hatte ich auch mal Schmerz.
Der war aber nicht so lange.
Es war nur ein paar Stunden.
Ich hatte stechende Schmerz auf der linken Seite.
Aber es ist dann wieder weggegangen und kam nicht wieder.
Jetzt habe ich aktuell keine Schmerzen.
In den linken Bauch?
Ja, richtig.
Wie sieht Ihr Haut aus?
Geht es nicht?
Ein bisschen blass bin ich schon.
Aber ich weiß nicht genau, ob das normal ist bei dem Fieber.
Oder ob das sein muss.
Oder Ihr Augen, wie sieht es aus?
Ich habe es nicht drauf geachtet.
Ich habe mir nicht so viel aufgefallen.
Herr Begemann, ich würde gerne wissen,
ob Sie die Vorerkrankungen haben?
Eigentlich nicht.
Aber ich muss Ihnen sagen,
dass ich beruflich sehr oft unterwegs bin.
Ich war jetzt auch vor drei Wochen
wieder im Ausland gewesen.
Vor drei Wochen?
Ja.
Was ist Ihr Beruf?
Ich bin in der Entwicklungshilfe tätig.
Ich bin Ingenieur.
Ich arbeite in der Entwicklungshilfe.
Ich war auch vor drei Wochen in Indonesien.
In Indonesien?
Können Sie mir sagen,
sind Sie schon geïft?
Für die brauchte Impfung in Indonesien?
Ich habe schon geïft.
Ich habe alle Impfungen nachweisen.
Ich habe auch TÜVOS-Impfungen gemacht.
Alle Impfungen waren komplett gewesen.
Bevor ich auf der Reise bin.
Würden Sie schon operiert?
Sind Sie schon operiert?
Keine größere Operation.
Ich hatte immer Handgelenksbruch.
Aber das war alles.
Ich hatte nur eine Platte bekommen.
Aber schon sehr lange her.
20 Jahre her.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig etwas Medikament?
Nein.
Herr Begemann, haben Sie gegen etwas Allergie?
Oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Eine Routine-Frage.
Haben Sie Beroge-Erfahrung?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Gugelungen genommen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei kleine Kinder.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ihre Frau und Ihre Kinder sind gesund?
Sie sind so weit gesund.
Jetzt kommen wir zu Ihrer Familie.
Leben Ihre Eltern?
Ja, meine Eltern leben noch.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Die Mutter ist Ende 60.
Der Vater ist Anfang 70.
Sie sind bei dem Ruhestand.
Sie sind gesund.
Sie haben keine Krankheit.
Wir sind nun das Anastandemnöse-Gespräch beendet.
Ich möchte Sie etwas noch sagen.
Ich möchte etwas noch sagen.
Mani accurate einstellt.
Ich habe Parises Nadias merchants.
Ich möchte etwas noch sagen.
Ich möchte etwas noch realized.
everyone could hear it.
im Ausland und besonders Indonesien, dort könnten sie vielleicht etwas stecken,
nicht stecken, eine Parasite gehabt oder aus einem Trateriker, aber wir müssen erst
Körpern, die herumteilsuchen und etwas Blut abnehmen.
Okay, gut. Soll ich etwas gegen das Fieber nehmen oder was meinen Sie?
Ja, ich würde gerne Ihnen eine Medikamente geben und gegen Fieber, dann sprechen wir darüber.
Okay, was meinen Sie, ist das vom Ausland Infektion, was vorhin Sie jetzt sehen?
Ja, ich habe vielleicht Malaria.
Okay, okay. Gibt es dazu Fragen vom Chat?
Ich habe es in der Lesterzeit, eine Schwellung in der Halsbemerk, Schwellung oder Knoten.
Habe ich nicht gemerkt, aber warum fragen Sie?
Habe ich nach Schweiß?
Hat er gefragt, hat nach Schweiß, ja.
Ja, es könnte sein, die Fernseher, wir sind als Zünder, oder haben sie Apotheos zu genomen?
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Was meinen Sie?
Haben Sie Apotheos zu genomen in der letzten Zeit?
Apotheos zu genomen, hat er nicht.
Also bevor er Fieber hatte, hat er gleich Gewicht gehabt, seit dem Fieber hat er vielleicht ein bisschen abgenommen, aber vorher war kein Gewichtsverlust.
Aber welche Frage hätten Sie denn gestellt?
Ich habe vielleicht viel lange gedauert, das Fieber oder das Schuh oder Attack.
Eine gute Frage, also zwei, drei Stunden dauert es.
Was kann man noch fragen, wenn man letzten Verdacht Malaria hat?
Haben Sie Mückensteg in der Dönerse bemacht?
Zum Beispiel kann man fragen, aber hat er so oft mitgestichelt, hat er nicht gezählt, hat er gehabt.
Das ist eine gute Frage, was kann man noch fragen?
Er ist ja beruflich sehr oft unterwegs, auch ein paar Mal schon woanders gewesen, bestimmt.
Was macht man normalerweise, wenn man in solche Gegenden fährt, wo Malaria Risiko da ist?
Vielleicht haben Sie bemerkt etwas auf der Haut, eine Moskito oder ...
Was hat er gefragt, also Insektenstich oder Zeckenquist oder wie auch immer ...
Insektenstich, ja Insektenstich, ja Insektenstich, Zeckenquist, so was.
Das ist eine Frage, die man stellen sollte, vielleicht hat er gemerkt, vielleicht hat er nicht gemerkt.
Haben Sie letztens etwas besonders gegessen?
Das ist eine gute Frage, ja, das ist sehr wichtig zu wissen.
Aber jetzt nochmal auf die Malaria zurückzukommen, was kann man denn noch fragen?
Was machen denn, was sollen dann die Leute machen, die beruflich in die Tropen reisen?
Zumindest in manchen Regionen.
Richtig, haben Sie eine Malaria-Prophylaxe gemacht, würde ich fragen.
Er hat es nicht gemacht, weil er beim letzten Mal, er hat immer Übelkeit gehabt, wenn er die Tabletten genommen hat.
Wir haben das letzte Mal die Malaria-Prophylaxe nicht gemacht, ist aber auch kein hundertprozentiger Schutz, wenn man sie einnimmt.
Das muss man dazusagen, aber kann die Wahrscheinlichkeit ein bisschen eingrenzen, ja, genau.
Gut, sonst noch Fragen? Haben Sie Hautausschlag? Das ist eine gute Frage, ja.
War nicht gemerkt.
Farbveränderung der Haut hat er gefragt, auch mit den Sklären, aber hat es nicht so richtig gemerkt.
Vielleicht gab es einen Hinweis aus der Anäse, die Hinweise geben könnten auf diese Frage, die Sie gestellt haben.
Warum fragen Sie denn nach Farbveränderung der Haut?
Warum?
An alle jetzt?
Warum ist das wichtig?
Herr Doktor, warum ist wichtig nach der Hautfarbe oder den Sklären zu fragen?
Also, ja, ich habe gedacht, vielleicht, Sie haben gesagt Bauchschmerzen, ich habe gedacht, vielleicht Pancreatitis oder die anderen Differenzialdiagnose.
Okay, okay.
Und dann fragen Sie nach Haut, weil Sie an Icterus vermuten, ja?
Icterus, ja.
Okay, das wollte ich hören.
Erwarten, aber nicht.
Nein, das ist nicht gesagt.
Eine Sache hat er gesagt, was vielleicht Hinweis auf Icterus oder auf, was ist denn die Ursache für den Icterus bei Ihnen in seinem Fall?
Es könnte sein, aber Pancreatitis oder Galenstein.
Leberinfektionsphäos, malerie Perusach, Leberinfektionsphäos.
Kann sein, aber es wäre sehr extremer voll.
Hemolyse, richtig, das wollte ich hören.
Hemolyse.
Das ist hemolytische Icterus, kann sein, richtig.
Ich bin dem Ogali auch.
Ja, genau, hat er Schmerzen gehabt, linke Oberbau, könnte sein.
Nein, das ist gut, ja, ja.
Hat sich die Farbe des Urins verne, hat gesagt, er war einmal ein bisschen dunkel gewesen, er hat wenig getrunken,
kann aber auch mal im Rahmen einer hemolytischen Schubis sein, dass die Urin sich verändert hat, richtig, genau.
Und die Schmerzen im Oberbau, linken Oberbau, kommen woher?
Den Omegali.
Ja, aber es kann manchmal, hat er gesagt, es war akut, ganz stark, und dann war es nach 2 Stunden wieder weg.
Was kann da passiert sein?
Das ist ja immer eher eine chronische Veränderung, oder zumindest mal ein Superkut.
Was gibt es denn für akute Probleme bei Malaria Schub?
Mit Schubdüff könnte sein, aber ich weiß nicht, wie es hier kann sein.
Dann wäre aber vielleicht noch nicht mehr so gut bei einer Nese.
Nepholytiasis, oder?
Was kann noch passieren, selten mal.
Eine Milznegrose, was ist die Vorstufe von Negrose in der Milz?
Ein Milzinfakt.
Milzinfakt kann man geben, in den Hemolytis, sag ich mal, so Bestandteile, die Blutgefäße verstopfen können.
Kann mal sein, Milzinfakt, okay.
Das war vermutlich das Problem bei den Patienten.
Gut, aber wir haben jetzt sehr viele wichtige Fragen gestellt, sehr gut.
Gut, wollen Sie dann zur Oberarztvorstellung gehen?
Ja, wenn Sie seithaben.
Ich habe Zeit, ja. Bitte schön.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt, ich habe einen Patienten aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie seithaben, würde ich gerne Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen.
Bitte schön, ja.
Herr Begemann ist ein 40-jähriger Patient,
der heute wegen seit einer Woche Fieber über 39 Grad und Fieberschübe zum Kampf ist.
Und das Fieber ist nicht Ganzen-Tag und Ganzenwoche.
Das ist wie Fieberschübe.
Ein Tag ist 39 Grad Fieber, und das dauert 3-4 Stunden.
Dann geht normal Fieber, normaler Fieber.
Dann zwei Tage Pause, dann kommt noch mal Fieber.
Er hat folgende Symptome begleitet.
Er hat das Fieber vom folgenden Symptom begleitet.
Er hat das Fieber von Kopfschirmesen seit ein paar Tagen.
Er hat die Übelkeit von Nausea und Erbrechen erbrechen.
Er hat bemerkt, dass er einen Dünnerschutul 2-mal ein Jahr am Tag hat.
Und dass er die dunkle Wasserlassen bemerkt hat.
Und die dunkle Urin.
Er hat gesagt, dass er in der letzten Zeit schlechte Appetit hat.
Er fühlt sich schlecht und fühlt sich ganz im Körper krank.
Er hat die linke Abdomen im Milchbereich schmerzt.
Er hat keine Vorerkrankungen.
Er wurde schon lange Handgenächt, Fraktur operiert.
Medikation und Allergie sind unauffällig.
Er ist nicht rauchig.
Er trinkt kein Alkohol.
Die Familienanwohner sind unauffällig.
Seine Familien sind ruhig.
Es ist ein wichtiges Erwähnis, dass er beruflich Enginieur und Entwicklungsprojekt arbeitet.
Er war vor drei Wochen im Ausland Indonesien.
Nach der Rückkehr hat er Beschwerden.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Er hat auch gegen Reisekrankheiten vollständig geimpft.
Das war alles.
Ich habe den Patienten Medikamente gegeben.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtsdiagnose ist aufgrund der angeblichen Angaben gehe ich aus Malaria.
Ich werde die Folgen der Massnahmen durchführen.
Ich mache eine körperliche Untersuchung, eine Inspektion und andere.
Ich mache eine Blutbild.
Ich nehme eine Blutab.
Ich sehe eine Heimatolische Anode an die Hemoglobin und LDH.
Ich sehe eine Nivelle von Schaue.
Ich erwarte die Untersuchung der Pallpassion.
Ich entfelle die Folgen der Therapie.
An die Malaria Medikamente können Sie mich verschreiben.
Was sind Differenzialdiagnose?
Differenzialdiagnose kann ich mitdrücken.
Oder eine andere Virusinfektion?
Es kann jede Art von Infektion sein.
Infektius, viral, parasitär, mikrobiäl.
Bei jedem Patienten, der aus dem Ausland aus Malaria kommt,
muss man immer einen Malaria haben.
Dengifieber, viral.
Wie bewerten Sie, dass der Patient nicht regelmäßig Fieber hat?
Am Anfang war es nur jeden zweiten Tag?
Fieberschübe?
Ist das oft bei Malaria so?
In der Fieber?
Eigentlich hat er einen Tag Fieber und einen Tag kein Fieber.
Dann hat er ein paar Tage regelmäßig Fieber.
Ist das normal für Malaria?
Nicht nur an Malaria, ich erwarte auch Rheumatöte.
Ist das regelmäßig?
Fieber hat und dann zwei Tage kein Fieber.
Welche Malariaform kennen Sie?
Der Pediatrie muss es sein.
Geht es in der Türkei kein Malaria mehr?
Es gibt verschiedene Formen.
Malaria, Tertiana oder Quartana, wo die regelmäßig Fieberschübe sind.
Ein Tag Fieber haben einen Tag nicht.
Tertiana, Quartana, wo die Patienten Fieber haben,
dann zwei Tage kein Fieber.
Das ist der Rhythmus der Parasiten.
Sie können sich wieder erneuern und zerfallen.
Deswegen ist es dieses Rhythmische.
Es ist oft so, dass verschiedene Generationen von Parasiten heranwachsen.
Es ist oft nicht mehr so Rhythmisch.
Die Patienten haben teilweise so jeden Tag Fieber.
Es gibt diese Formen, wo man regelmäßig Fieber hat.
Alle zwei Tage zum Beispiel.
Malaria, Quartana.
Die Tropica ist unregelmäßig, weil verschiedene Generationen
gleichzeitig erwachsen können.
Das wäre ein Hinweis für Malaria, wenn es so regelmäßig abständig wäre.
Dicke Tropfen haben Sie gesagt.
Ich habe mir einen kleinen Werte geguckt.
Gibt es irgendwelche späzifischen Laborveränderungen bei Malaria?
Ich erwarte auch LDH.
Warum ist LDH öhrt bei Malaria?
Wegen ziblernden.
Wo kommt LDH her?
Wegen hemolyse.
Was kann man noch bestimmen für eine hemolyse Parameter?
Belübien.
Welches Belübien ist erhöht?
Inderexbelübien.
Was gibt es noch für eine hemolyse Parameter?
Aus der Belübien LDH?
Trombostopäne, Lycopenostopäne.
Ich habe noch einen Protein, den man in Blut messen kann.
Was bei hemolytischen Anämie.
Abtoglobin ist ein Niedrig.
Ja, PCR gibt es mittlerweile auch.
Aber die Hauptdiagnose-Spitze ist durch die Schmikroskopie gestellt.
Haben Sie in der Pediatrie ein Malaria-Fall gehabt?
Ich habe keine Erfahnung.
Ich habe in Deutschland schon Malaria-Fälle gesehen.
In der Pediatrie.
Ich habe 18 Monate gearbeitet.
Auch mikroskopisch.
Das waren Flüchtlinge aus Pakistan und Afghanistan.
Da hat Malara als Kind in der Pediatrie.
Oder auch, weil ich den Frankfurter Flughafen wohne an Frankfurt.
Es kommen viele Leute aus dem Umkreis.
Wenn die Fliegen in die Unikliniken haben, dann kommen sie in die Unikliniken.
Da sieht man oft nicht. Aber ab und zu mal Malaria-Fälle.
Das kann man mit mikroskopisch gut erkennen.
Diese Plasmodien in den Erdrucksüten.
Ich arbeitete in Istanbul 3 Monate.
Nur einmal habe ich gesehen,
dass ich die Diagnose-Pfälice habe.
Ich hätte erwartet, dass mehr ist in der Türkei.
Das ist früher nicht mehr.
Eine französische Kind.
In vielen Landkarten,
wo die Malaria-Risiko beschrieben wird,
ist immer noch Türkei farbig.
Deswegen wäre in der Türkei mehr Malaria-Fälle.
Wo? Im Osten?
Im Südosten.
Wir haben keine ländlichen Fälle.
Alles in Afrika.
Alles ausländische Fälle.
Gibt es noch Kommentare?
Vielleicht müssen wir diese Krankheit
beim Gesundheitsamts melden.
Gute Frage. Muss man Malaria melden?
Ja, muss melden.
Aber nur die Krankheit. Die Krankheit nicht sehe ich gerade.
Ich habe gerade eine Tabelle aufgemacht.
Aber ich würde es melden.
Ich habe eine Regermeldung.
Ich muss noch mal nachgucken.
In 2x2 würde ich melden.
Wie war die Vorstellung?
Ich habe mich aufgeregt.
Das war meine erste Anästhe.
Dann noch besser.
Bestanden Sie mit?
Die Fragen waren sehr gut gestellt.
Es war alles sehr gut.
Okay.